journalism today
i believe just about everybody reporting
the news has some kind of agenda their
starting off point
is not ground zero it's from where they
are on the left or the right
and it's very confusing or very
difficult for news consumers to
find anything to trust so it's crucial
that we really examine what journalism
is and should be
and teach people proper journalism
because
it's the conduit it's what we all need
it's what ties us together and how we
communicate and understand what's going
on in our
city our town our world i have
throughout
much of my career on talk radio
interviewed professors people from
hillsdale
and i said during the interview why
don't we have more hillsdale colleges in
this country
and i got a letter a couple of weeks
later and they said
we really agree with you so we're going
to start
a scholarship in your name for hillsdale
college i just i was beside myself i
couldn't believe it
the scholarship will be used for a
bright ambitious student from michigan
who is interested in journalism and
radio
the journalism program at hillsdale
college
has produced great success stories we
have former students of hillsdale now
working
at the wall street journal the detroit
news and
many other publications the radio
journalism program
at hillsdale radio free hillsdale has
won numerous awards and they've just
been named the best college radio
station in michigan
hillsdale college has a great journalism
program because the students there
like all hillsdale students they learn
about foundational
things they should know like our
constitution why do we have freedom in
this country what's it all about
and it gives them context to report on
everything so you
match a classical education with
journalism
and you're going to produce responsible
trustworthy
knowledgeable journalists in the future
this is a matching
scholarship and and that means anybody
who supports hillsdale for
the education that they provide you can
donate any amount and it will be doubled
so you can donate ten dollars
and you'll make an impact and that will
be doubled twenty dollars a hundred any
amount
one thousand ten thousand you name it
please give to the ron jolly challenge
at hillsdale college before our deadline
and remember
whatever you give will be doubled
[Music]